[Music]
good morning y'all today it's beautiful
day I've just finished working out
before Joe they're training for the
movie and even though I'm not in the
movie myself I figured why not go train
with them go be fit and just be healthy
overall so I just got out of the shower
but start my day and I'm wrapping up my
morning routine here now just thinking
to myself I'm getting a lot of themes
from you guys about eczema and about
what I do to treat my eczema and you
know just overall lifestyle choices I
figured I might as well make a blog
about that today and walk you through my
eczema day I guess my face is drying up
as we speak right now I can feel it
tightening up
I am partnered up with dove derma series
and they sent me a lot of products to
test out and try out and I am definitely
loving all of them I cannot complain
about any one of these products stuff
you guys have really given me in the
scent of to really take care of my skin
because growing up I was so bad about
taking care of my skin I mean it was if
the lotion was out of sight it's out of
mind because of the head I keep my
lotions right in plain view I will never
forget to put on lotions in the morning
I'm gonna put on my face cream first
just because my face is drying up right
now and I can already the mobility of my
facial expressions are diminishing as we
speak
[Music]
they can make my mom proud by being so
tentative to my skin because as a kid
forget about it the face cream first
because this is the moneymaker this is
this is what people see there was a time
it's a couple years back where this was
all woven red and that I never want to
go back to that in LA it's the weather
is still kind of confused as to whether
it wants to be summertime or spring it
just got cold a couple days ago too
because of that my allergies are going
crazy and uh and my skin is also
affected by the changes in weather and
even though I'm an excellent is under
control right now my face likes to peel
and be dried 24/7 and it's la this is
desert weather out here it's not like
we're in the tropics so after my face is
done next one is body lotion I don't
know if you guys can see but my skin is
already like ashing up like you see the
whites white little skin flaky areas I
mean I just stepped out the shower I
mean this show so this room is still
kind of humid nice and after these two
we got the duck drum series repairing
fall it's much much thicker my hands
over the years have always been the most
problematic I like to put it on that
knuckles this is where I get the driest
on the man geez
[Music]
admit it all into the office let her
drive today just happens to be jaqen
news day so check this at the office
eyes exact school so I got the house all
to myself I love my family but I do have
to say I do get a lot more work done
when they're gone so I'm about to bang
on some work see you on the flip side
[Music]
after working for some time my hands do
end up getting a little more dryer as
the day progresses another product from
Dove that I really like is the hand
cream that they have and this is like
the lightest of all their products that
they have the way I think if it is in
the morning isn't I've applied the
lotions to give me the moisturize skin
for the whole day and then this little
guy here is what I use to help maintain
our central body oils do tend to rub off
on its own
and for people like me that have eczema
or just general dry skin our hands don't
know how to replenish itself so because
the problem with most hand lotions is
that they're thick and they kind of tend
to leave a film over your hands
I think the doves formula is actually
the most ideal doesn't leave that film
and I can touch this camera without
thinking on getting the camera dirty oh
no I think it's time to make some lunch
now tisn't at home and there was a few
things that I can't do when she is home
so I know I've mentioned before that
TIFF loved my baked salmon recipe but
for some reason she doesn't like any
other fish maybe salmon has become
mainstream salmon is now kind of like
the omega-3 fats poster child of
proteins
so many more fishes out there that I
love eating and TIFF doesn't like the
smell of fish and after a couple times
of me making fish at home
that wasn't salmon he came up with the
compromise to not make fish whenever
she's home except for salmon and when
she's not home like we make fish all I
want since she's not home I am going in
on some mackerel today and as long as
we're talking about skin conditions and
what's good it healthy for your skin I
just want to add that keeping your skin
healthy is a complete lifestyle
adjustments there are a few things out
there that you can eat that will
complement your your regiment of lotions
and a lot of times dry skin is the
direct result of poor diet and as much
as I struggle with my eczema I kind of
have to thank eczema for forcing me to
be healthier with my life and allowing
me to be more fit because without eczema
and a just amount of diet for it I think
I'll be eating a lot more unhealthy
foods it's like a win-win situation
control your diet and you get to stay
fit and healthy and also you get to
control your eczema anyways here is the
recipe for roasted mackerel with garlic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right it smells good in here
Thursday's are definitely my play days
in the kitchen TIFF you're missing out
yeah all right time to air out the house
all right that gives me a couple hours
to air out the house get rid of the fish
smell and get back to work washed off
all the hand cream when I was cooking
gotta rehydrate after cooking all right
here we go second half of the day let's
do it
[Music]